hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess olympiad we have a very very nice
game that features uh an incredibly wild
line of the taj defense uh one of the
more wild ones that we've seen on this
channel uh so let's dive straight into
it it's india's second team first board
gookish versus board one for italy
daniel vocatoro
let's uh let's enjoy the game so lukas
has the wide pieces and he opens with d4
we have knight to f6 c4 e6 knight to f3
and d5 the queen's gambit declined this
on the board knight to c3 and like we've
advertised pawn to c5 the semitarash is
on the board c characters on d5 and now
we often mention that you can capture
here with the knight you can capture
with the pawn or if you want to really
play some wild chess you can play c
characters on d4 and that is exactly
what vocator plays so here c characters
on d4 uh we have queen captures on d4
and now e captures on d5 with bishop to
g5 nicely developing
the bishop and the bishop to e7 we have
pawn to e3 preparing to develop the
light score bishop as well uh and
bogaturo castles rook to d1 by ghoukish
and now comes bishop to e6 uh there is a
game uh between magnus cross and
yanipanishi from this year's earthings
masters where nepal played knight to c6
that game ended in a draw uh but here
like i said we have bishop to e6 and now
uh bishop to e2 and d3 are the standard
ideas that were used here in the past
but here we have queen to a4 by goku and
it is now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so once the knight
comes to c6 it will not be attacking the
queen and now the d file has been opened
up to the white rook so what's uh what's
the idea here there are some tricks here
of course uh can you allow bishop
captures bishop captures and uh
can can the d5 pawn be captured at some
point uh we'll see uh so here h6
challenging the bishop and now bishop
captures and on f6 bishop captures and
now the d5 pawn is defended twice
however uh here goku goes for knight
captures and d5 and this is the
move that he he prepared in this like i
said it was a new line as already as of
move 10. uh bishop captures on d5 so he
sacrifices a piece uh is it temporarily
or not we'll have to see what he
prepared for this and now queen to b5
preparing to win back the the bishop
here we have bishop captures on b2
there's no good way to save the bishop
and now how do you capture back do you
just ignore uh the the bishop do do just
continue development something like
bishop p2 do play queen captures and
b2 do play rook captures on d5 all of
these are valid questions but uh mainly
what happens if queen captures on b2 is
what we will discuss briefly point is
that now uh after knight to c6 and queen
b5 it seems like white will just uh win
back uh win another piece he already won
the piece back now he's going to win the
bishop here there's this tricky knight
to e7 move and guarding the the bishop
here and if you play e4
then there's a6
and that's that's the problem so even
though it looks like it could be working
it really uh isn't and
it's even more complicated than this for
example queen a4 now rook e8
what is what is this now point is if you
capture the bishop just knight captures
on d5 with check and if bishop b2 just
rook captures on e2 king captures knight
c3 check uh forks the king and the queen
and now after king f1 you trade queens
knight captures here rook captures here
rook captures here and you get this
position where uh black is up upon but
the black is also just
completely winning this is a well-known
winning position
uh so although you can play it uh you
can't win both of the bishops by playing
it so here goku goes for rook captures
on d5 instead attacks the queen now
comes bishop to c3 with chuck first
taking care of this and now king to d1
so this forces the white king to remain
in the center of the board but it's
still not a problem as vulkaturo still
has to
develop all of his pieces so hero queen
to e7
and now bishop the c4 now preparing king
to e2 and the other rook might come to
d1 so knight to a6 now preparing knight
to c7 with a nice fork here uh king the
e2 and now uh can you can you just fork
the queen and the rook well if you play
knight to c7 there's rook d7 and
although you can play it it's uh
won't really be all that much for black
knight cat person b5 now rook captures
an e7 the knight is hanging and it's a
very very tricky position okay you can
go back 96 bishop b3 and this is
basically what you get equal material
uh with white um
being uh a bit more active but still
it's two rooks a knight and the bishop
versus two rooks and knight and the
bishop same amount of pawns um
of course it can be played uh so king e2
we have rook ate the c8 instead uh and
now comes queen back to b3 uh now this
definitely is a threat so queen back to
b3 and did not knight to b4
we have rook to f5 putting more pressure
on this f7 pawn and here comes bishop
back to f6
the bishop is
currently being attacked so you have to
move it but it's a question is it uh
the absolute best move vocatoro has
queen to d7 looks to be even stronger as
it attacks the rook and once the rook
moves or you defend it now you play
queen c7 you put pressure on the bishop
and it's a very very long line uh but a
very enjoyable one so i'm going to show
it to you bishop captures an f7 rook
captures now the rook remains pinned
here now you play a3 you chase away the
knight knight to a6 or c6 and then it's
uh you know we can just capture back the
bishops on 96 and now rook to c1 going
after the bishop queen to c for check
you can even trade queens here but it
doesn't matter queen captures rook
captures rook captures on f7 king
captures and now you win back your piece
with king to d3 with a double attack
rook captures here we're going to play
rook captures and c3 and again equal
material and most likely should end in a
draw however after bishop to f6 this
gives gookish a bit too much
not a bit too much but
a bit more uh you know stuff to work
with and he goes rook to b5 now puts
pressure on the knight it's attacked
twice and also if the knight moves then
just rook captures and b7 so a5 is what
vocaturo comes up with it defends the
knight but also uh gives up the a5 pawn
rook captures and now knights the c6
with an attack on the rook so look back
to b5 threatening the b7 pawn and now
even pawn to b6 saying okay if you
capture on b6 i can play knight a5 and
then uh it's going to be a problem the
queen is attacked the bishop is attacked
twice uh so you don't want to do this so
after this b6 move we have bishop to d5
by gokush and now you have to play
knight to a5 however knight the a7 was
played in the game and now uh it just uh
it's just too difficult
to play against this rook captures on b6
now you have a beautiful past a pawn
here rook to c3 getting uh some activity
here for the rook and now queen to b1
you have to be careful not to play
something like queen to b2 and go under
the mask of the bishop so here queen b1
and now queen the c5 trying to put some
pressure on the white king rook to d1 so
now you can start hiding your king the
rook is in the game uh rook the c
teacher king to f1 and now rook to d8 so
it seems volcaturo has fully developed
and he is now ready to go after the
white king but you could not be further
from the truth if that's what you were
thinking because here knight e1 attacks
the rook rook to c3 and here comes the
move bishop captures an f7 probably the
one i've chosen for the thumbnail
and the problem is the rook on d8 is
defended but only for the moment uh
if you capture the bishop which you
cannot do for example king captures
we're going to play rook captures on f6
and simply remove the defender of this
rook and now it doesn't matter what you
play if you play king captures on f6
they just wrote capture 78 and this is
not winning look at the queen
controlling all of these squares the
rook controls the back rank i mean the
that black king will not survive there
for very long and she can't present f6
is even worse because now you just allow
queen to h7 check and uh you're gonna
pick up the rook next if the king
defends the rook which can even go for a
nice check and after king e7 queen
captures and now of course a few more
moves and the black king will get
checkmated so after bishop captures an
f7 you cannot capture the bishop can you
go here not really because rook captures
an f6 again wins the game g captures
rook capture 78 with chuck and now of
course you're just getting checkmated
with queen to g6 so the only thing you
can do is came to a f8 uh but it's not
all that much better uh bishop to h5 now
uh preparing queen g6 and queen f7
checkmate knight to c6 and now we have
rook capture 78 we have bishop capture
78 and now queen to g6 threatening queen
f7 checkmate uh queen to c4 with check
king to g1 and now king e7 trying to
hide the king trying to run away a
little bit but here luke has just played
rook to b7 check and he was in this
position on move 34 that daniel vogturo
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you are in check
all of the squares are taken if you go
back then just queen to queen g7 is
checkmate or even queen to e8 is
checkmate uh and if you don't to go back
well there's really no square for you
you have to block with the bishop and
then once you capture now you can go
here but now queen to d6 will be checked
maybe the bishop covers the eight square
so game over
so really uh a nice game by both of them
but uh
really really show uh showed how it's um
possible to to play this semitash or
rather against the semitarsh with this
queen to a4 maneuver just a very very uh
exciting stuff uh and very very original
so the india's second team wins another
game uh or a rather another not just
game but also a match as um they've also
won on board two so i believe these are
all wins for them so far and lucas is
currently on four out of four which is
incredible here you can see that his
rating is to
but the ratings get updated once a month
so his actual live rating is something
like 27.08 he's currently number 30 in
the world uh and he has improved his
classical rating you know quite quite
rastly it's
2708.3 so uh he is uh just this month he
has won 24.3 points and he is uh
currently on the live rating list number
30 player in the world um
if you consider classical rating uh so
yeah that's the game and uh a little bit
of info about ratings hope you guys uh
enjoyed that uh i would like to thank
david kimura uh michaela kalista harper
isla esmendalden and jacob tobias for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
olympiad until it finishes so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day